Telegraph that pass Beverly in the
corner 322 play Kauai impressive
he went up top on that one right there
Brian we all look at the best steer
leader in the building
[Applause]
mark the smart jumpshot Goddard would
Walker back out Marcus smart behind the
back dribbles across the lane throws it
up
[Applause]
Beverly corner three bucks in a lurch
George on the drive inside arrow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
drives George right there Tatum gets a
lot of the inbounder is grant Williams
so they trust late-game so Marcus smart
just hands-off I wouldn't mind seeing
that again like they're making that live
it looks to me initially like their feet
get tangled that's exactly what happens
to me Paul falls because their feet get
tangled why one turnovers for the
Clippers 64 the suffix Tatum finds a
room just shot is good but okay for
Tatum he's got 26 not play Leonard or
George passed the minutes I don't know I
don't think so I think right now that's
the number one thing is George puts up
another three and this time nails it and
the Clippers go up one George kicks it
out Beverly another corner three
[Applause]
Peg's Johnson much time
[Applause]
Jaden gets a pass from smart and backs
it on knives on both sides looked pretty
cast right now doors Harald corner
Beverly sets it up Boston you so much
made of the acquisition Hawaii gets one
stop Paul George gets the oven dives on
both sides looked pretty cast right now
doors
Errol corner Beverly sets it up Boston
big buckets from Beverly 14 points 16
rebounds 7 assists and the Clippers back
in control make no mistake that the
improvement of montrezl harrell
contributes greatly here if you're a big
this is the past you have to be able to
make the trap out front the ball gets
delivered to the center of the floor you
better be able to see it and make it and
mantras patients look what are your eyes
see on the catch at Patrick Beverley
look at your teammates and Beverly has
been really struggling from three-point
range he came into tonight's game
shooting 19% from free tonight he's 4 of
7
[Music]